let's talk about it with one of our
favorites kyle brown of good morning
football and the
the uh ten questions with kyle brandt
podcast on the ringer in spotify how are
you kyle
rich electric moment in the brown
household a few days ago
we've kind of worn out our shows and our
entertainment and everything we've
watched so many this year so we're going
back to things that we missed yes
and we found this show that we're loving
and it's called i'm sorry i've never
seen the show
i'm in the kitchen my wife works on the
couch she starts yelling come here come
here get in here get in here
wait wait wait i look up on the screen
yes and i see eisen
staring back at me they're at your house
you're giving away goldfish i thought i
knew about it
i saw you in billions i've seen you a
bunch of things i didn't know you were
i'm sorry i want to say to you i'm sorry
i wish i would have been there that
looked like a blast it was a total blast
kyle and you know don't you don't have
to apologize for anything because i like
just sneaking up on people
yeah i like sneaking up on people and uh
andrea savage
who's dynamite i mean she is the creator
and writer and she
directed the episode that i was in um
she's just
brilliant um her daughter and my son go
to the school
same school together so okay you know
and her husband jeremy's like hey you
know there's a role that
you might be perfect for would you be up
for it and i'm like are you kidding me
absolutely where i play a clueless dad
um
who gives a who's who's uh whose kid
is having a birthday party and the uh
the giveaway is a goldfish which only
serves
to create a problem in a household for a
parent because the goldfish in
inevitably will die and you now have to
talk about death with your child
and um i thought that was a brilliant
construct and i'll be honest with you uh
kyle
the one scene you're referring to is the
only scene i'm in it and i was
disappointed when i got the script
that i was only in one scene and then i
saw how uh i'm referenced
the rest of the show uh with a curse
word
uh associated with my name and i'm like
ah that actually might be better
yeah but i saw an association with your
name and
the concept of that show that's great is
that yes there's kid time and parenting
but then there's the way that the adults
talk when the kids aren't around
and there's a moment in which uh her
husband who is the the drummer from the
wonders yes
walks away from talking to you and is is
palpably titillated from talking to you
and
she says something about oh put away
your rich eyes and then rhymes with
loner
and i was like wow that sounds that
sounds like a fantasy team name
that was an amazing legacy and a phrase
to follow you around
so congratulations thank you i'm gonna
go deeper down this wormhole with you
because i gave
i gave it i gave andrea an idea um
that she never put into a show um but
the idea was born out of
she was in the room and i was in the
room uh in the same audience
at my son's and her daughter's school
and they were in the same school
production
same play okay and before the production
started
the teachers who were in charge of the
production
thanked all the parents who were helping
out throughout the entire production
making sure it could happen
okay and she said she didn't want to
miss
any of the parents names so if all the
parents who are involved in putting the
production together could just stand up
so we can give everyone a round of
applause
and that happened and my idea was
what if i was one of the parents who
absolutely had nothing to do with the
production
but stood up in that moment to accept
applause for being part of it when
everyone knew i wasn't
i wanted to be that guy and create the
sort of problem of
do you call that person out how do you
call that person out how do you shame
that person
who has no shame to accept that in front
of the entire
parent population i think that's a i
would love that
that's the next role i would want to
play rich i don't know if it is
yeah the jet fan in you or maybe the the
coffee mug that's to your right right
now but that is a very larry
video storyline right there larry would
completely call bs on the parent who
stands for the applause that they did
exactly like would you call the person
out like what would you do
like hey i know for a fact you had
nothing to do with this
sit down you know like it reminds me of
when
uh larry and cheryl go out to dinner
with a couple that are friends with
and afterwards when the other person
picks up the check they think
they think the gentleman picks up the
check and then the wife says don't you
want to thank me too
that's right she's like why you don't
work why would i thank you and it
becomes this terribly awkward thing that
she thinks she deserves the thanks which
maybe she does but larry wasn't given a
shortcut
my gosh my dad may he rest in peace
loved
that episode absolutely
god he loved loved loved all that kyle
brandt here uh on the rich eisen show
you just mentioned uh uh by by uh by
mentioning the jets uh i guess
in a way what happened with the jets the
end of this week where does this rank
for you in your football viewing
sending eight men uh at a quarterback in
that situation to leave
the rookie um playing his fifth game and
undrafted rookie on an island against
henry ruggs where does that all rank
what greg williams dialed up
for you what's up there it's a half
measure i mean he could
he sent eight he could have sent 11.
he actually kept a few people back and
every layer of this is weird i think one
of the most underrated layers
yes is that the cornerback who was
beaten his name is lamar jackson that's
right what the hell is
an undrafted rookie from nebraska named
lamar jackson who
god it got to help him it's not his
fault um
i i was wondering if there was going to
be a buddy ryan kevin gilbride moment on
the sidelines right adam gase
literally assaulting greg williams and i
wouldn't have blamed him
like if if you don't stand for anything
at this point
listen say what you want about the jets
whether the organization wants to win or
lose i have to think adam gates wants to
win the game of course
and one was just completely taken from
him so it's
i gotta admit i love listening to you
guys during the commercial and i
i heard the name ik and empoli which is
just
filed away in like a 2013 uh time
capsule for me
yes um but it's up there with adam polly
and we've talked about this before rich
there's only like
three highlights in in jets history and
i
i think it's joe waving the finger
running off after the super bowl jumbo
elliott in the monday night miracle and
bart scott saying can't wait
those are the three good ones but
there's 500 bad ones and
i can't think of a better one even even
this side of the butt fumbles blastoises
as uh derek carr to henry ruggs b beat
lamar jackson well even crazier is i
just
shot the latest episode of the grind
that's going to be on epics tonight
uh at nine eastern time i shot it
yesterday i had no idea but of course
nfl films which produces it knows this
sort of thing
that rugs catch was
50 years to the day to the day
when the old oakland raiders did it to
the jets in shea stadium with a bomb
from the middle of the field to beat
them
like literally yeah i didn't know that
and they're going to show that footage
tonight
was that uh throw or is that the right
air i don't remember that way
it's got to be you know i'm so cool 50
years to the day
it's insane it's insane when these two
teams get together i got kyle brandt
here on the rich eisen show okay
um to me the week 14 schedule
uh certainly on the afc side is like a
scheduled version of an angry run
where you know where where it just makes
me want to get up off the couch
and just go and and and stand up and go
hit somebody myself
i'd this is i mean kudos to the chef
you know and howard katz and mike north
and the rest of the crew sure i mean
and i i just want to walk down it with
you certainly starting with the steelers
team that you said was going to go to
the super bowl
pre-season just coming off of their
first loss
could would you say that the 21st
century version and i know that he's
been playing most of his football in the
20th century
obviously all of it but josh allen is
this generation's version of big ben
what do you think about that idea i like
it i like the stature i like the arm
um when i was coming off watching that
bills game the next morning
which i think i think was the best game
of josh allen's professional career i
agree with that i
i came away saying this guy looks like
six foot five aaron rodgers like he
looks like a steely
cold-blooded sniper and
i'm i'm there with you on the
roethlisberger but honestly
even better than big ben even even when
in ben's early young young career
winning super i think josh allen looked
more talented
and a better runner like he looked the
other night like a top three guy
because the thing is always with him
it's just you need some poise
i i always compare him to like johnny
knoxville
like it's he's just crazy sometimes he
pulls laterals out of his backside and
he throws it that people weren't
receivers he just
it's like he gets a little sugar high
sometimes not in that game
i mean his pulse did not bounce the
entire time and these are the games
on national television now the games
that count and josh allen over the next
month
is going to be one of the few faces of
the league he's on national tv
a bunch including this sunday night
against the steelers team
that can't catch a pass can't make a
tackle like
there's there's blood on the water on
pittsburgh they went from 11-0 to
like sound the alarm right now well and
and because
they i guess conor needs to come back
healthy can't have big ben throw it 50
times you just can't
just cannot do that certainly against a
team like washington i mean you're
you're you're basically running straight
into the the headwind with something
like that
yeah and the way that the bills looked
again i know that the
49ers uh are getting inconsistent play
from their quarterback but the the
the bill's defense uh i would say is
going to be amped
this is it's one of those games man i
wish there were fans i mean could you
imagine
the the western new york getting
lubricated uh everybody
from pittsburgh coming up straight
straight line to be hanging out and
burning
tables in the parking lot all day i mean
that would be this would be amazing
it's why we got into this i know and
then i know i'm ben
yes this is the time of year rich when
when the rich quarterbacks
they get their their receivers and their
linemen the gifts and they
they get them the watch or the fancy
grill or the atv
or they get the gifts and they have
everybody puts on instagram is great if
i'm roethlisberger i'm going to say
enough of this i'm trying to win a super
bowl this year this may be my last year
i'm going to get from my wide receivers
i'm going to get them a gift i'm going
to buy
each one of them a signature jugs
machine
with an extension cord so they can put
it in their back seat and remember
how to catch and i'm going to put that
on instagram because these receivers
juju and claypool they're great on tick
tock
and good for them and god bless them
they've been terrible
terrible on the field i mean it's your
point about the bills game
the steelers receivers have been
embarrassed two weeks in a row and
they're likable guys young energetic
group
they're gonna go against the trey white
and jordan poyer and those guys in the
bill's secondary and the steelers better
find their dignity back because the
steelers receivers completely embarrass
themselves get them just
sucky that's close there it was i think
you got to call it yeah that's the
co-sign from the coach right there
that's our yeah that's our new drop off
sucking we got that
um so uh mahomes in two or two man
oh my god right i mean just when you
know the dolphins by the way i was
talking about this because i you know
one of my if you will four downs
yesterday was uh
the saints are a defensive team that you
know and dressed up in uh offensive guru
clothing sure they're great
right and but uh pittsburgh has the the
number one scoring defense giving up
just 17.6
right behind him is miami 17.7 here we
go
kyle van noy was all over the place and
i know cincinnati cincinnati
but uh this defense is ready to roll
flores uh
wants to have a pelt on the wall and
here comes kansas city coming in
after a few weeks where they haven't
been dominant i mean they have i mean
it's been a walk
the jets game was the last time where
mahomes did whatever he wanted to do
and there really was nothing in doubt
okay and they've played it all they
played it all like what happened against
denver this past week they also got in
the shooting match
with vegas right and kansas city also
had uh that game against tampo where
they got up big and did whatever they
wanted in one quarter and then had to
hold on for dear life
so this one's gonna be amazing too two
versus six
certainly if you think the steelers are
vulnerable later on that night
kansas city doesn't want to have
pittsburgh take the field knowing that
they
they've already lost too this is big i
can't really big
and i look at miami right now there was
that terrible ugly strange incident
against cincinnati with the two special
teams hits right
and i came out a monday morning on our
show in the morning and i said
i want to do a whole thing on brian
flores give me the tape of him give me
the incident i want i want to stand on a
soap box and scream about this
uh i was discouraged from doing that due
to sensitivity with the extracurriculars
and i appreciate that why however
brian flores i think won so much more
love and loyalty from the dolphins
locker room that he already had before
that
if you have your head coach i mean
actually standing in the middle of the
field
looking for a piece of someone look
there's a few coaches in the league who
would do that
there's a few coaches who would want to
make you think that they would do that
and they're posers and they want to be
held back
flores was ready and he's his message
was like you're going to hurt our guy
and if that's enough one time you can do
it second time i will literally fight
you right here on the field for men in
full pads
i got goosebumps when i saw it and i
can't even imagine being in the locker
room do not underestimate the power of a
miami team that totally believes in its
head coached on the last month of the
season
i think they're incredibly dangerous and
it would not shock me if they won this
weekend at all and then rookie receiver
lynne bowden jr went up to
flores after everyone went back to their
sidelines and tried to give
flores a fist bump and flores didn't
basically return to like i'm your head
coach
we don't fist bump your i don't do that
like i just was out there but
i'm back as on the sideline i'm your co
he does seem to be hitting every
note correctly um even with putting tua
back in and again i know it's cincinnati
if they win against kansas city you can
point to the fact that he got to a back
end against cincinnati as an important
uh an important moment and then this is
big for kansas city to basically say
okay you know
nice feel-good story but uh it's
midnight and you're a pumpkin again you
know like this is another one this is a
big
i can't tell you how exciting this game
is for me
as well as the one that we just
mentioned on sunday night football and
then you've got
uh a game that plays into our poll
question that i'm going to have chris
brockman ask you right now you've got
the colts
at the raiders right there on the if you
will new playoff mason-dixon line
um go for it chris brockman where you
got chris yeah kyle who ends up the
seventh seed in the afc
colts raiders ravens patriots
colts raiders ravens patriots um i
i do not believe in the patriots and i
know there's some of the most dangerous
words to say in all of sports media that
i think
were dangerous when tom brady was the
quarterback right uh cam right now is
reminding me
of something the boston fans have seen
before they were reminding me of
the big shamrock when shaquille o'neal
showed up at about 36 years old
contributed was fine but gassed not
himself
and the difference is that cam does not
have uh the big ticket and paul pierce
and ray allen around him he has uh
gunner olszewski god love him i do not
think the pages are going to get there
um the dolphins i really like
uh the raiders i
i am such a fan of the raiders brand and
company and i
want them in the afc playoffs it is
someone in the wwf
rail rumble that shakes things up it's a
bad guy it's the undertaker it's big
johnson i want them in
but god i just saw them get destroyed by
atlanta and
need what appeared to be an inside job
to beat the new york jets who might be
the worst team ever assembled so
i don't think it's going to be the
raiders and brockman tell me again who
am i missing
ravens and colts are your choice that
you've just narrowed it down to
i'm gonna go man what we saw last night
from baltimore is
is exactly what you don't want to see if
you're one of these teams like that
colts dolphins all these teams damn we
did not want to see lamar get going it
was like a uh
a proverbial home run hitter say whoever
you want
adam dunn ryan howard mark maguire who
hadn't hit one in a while and just
decided to swing out of his shoes and it
went about 600 feet
them getting that run game going shock
and awe um
absolute shock and awe so i'm gonna say
despite that my roundabout answer
i never count out frank reich frank
wright gets out of bed down four
touchdowns
in in a fight i still think the colts
are going to get there despite what
happened against tennessee i'll bet on
them
yeah and the ravens uh conference record
right now
is an awful tie break for them they're
they're that's the reason why they're
behind the raiders right now having the
same record um
their conference record is is a an issue
and a problem and here come the browns
who did who just i mean and again that's
the end push is the best
i know and that's what this week is
amazing it ends with it ends with the
browns trying to
just absolutely decleat the ravens i
mean the ravens as we know have
given the browns and baker mayfield
their worst losses
in the baker mayfield era and they're
they are even though as you mentioned
you know
uh having that home run hitter back in
the groove again they are still on the
ropes here
and boy i mean this would be the
knockout this would be just a way for
them to also say
we are here and we are for real and we
are a 10-win team for crying out loud
and we're going to break that 17 season
play-off drought and so on and so forth
that's why i love this week man
this week 14 is amazing yeah it just
stakes
the browns get to 10 wins and knock out
the mvp
the flip side of it being it is the
ultimate
back to the shallow end loss for the
browns should the baltimore ravens roll
over them it's like yeah
same old browns and guess what bigger
those commercials ain't so funny anymore
it's it's
the stakes it swings either way it's
going to be a huge statement next day
kyle thanks for the time man i'm glad
you found now i'm sorry it's a brilliant
show
that's a good one oh it's the best i'm
gonna go watch i'm sorry
uh rich in the meantime one of these
days we got to do this in person
yeah in the meanwhile i will be enjoying
my rich eisen phoner
that's it bro kyle you're the best and
your pot is off for the for the rest of
2020 is that what you're
in season two next year okay fantastic
and well done
uh thanks for the call we'll do it again
soon that's kyle brandt right here on
the rich housing show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here